Marcus how many screenplays have you
written a lot
films or or television or just or both
or a total just yeah whatever completed
yeah probably around fifty fifty okay
yeah how many scripts have you sold Oh
God
three what do you think it is about
those three versus the other whatever 47
well
not it's a very good question what is it
about those three I think it's probably
access you know you don't always write
what folks are looking for you don't
always write what folks are looking for
from you and folks aren't always looking
to read anything you know I mean when we
did I would die for you you know people
were the the town was hungry for like
what can I put Jennifer Love Hewitt in
and what can I put Ryan philippi in and
like you know all those people they were
hungry for that stuff and I wrote
something that fit that and so I was
like ah yeah it's great it was a fit it
made sense when I did genius it was an
independent film much more internally
generated and we worked really hard to
get funding to get that set up and made
and the production company that came on
board you know it was part of a slate
and they were putting their slate
together and we were fortunate enough to
have William Morris involved in the film
and the amazing amazing amazing
brilliant casseon lways involved and
Whoopi Goldberg
and Sharon Stone it all made sense but
you know the other things that I do
these films are not making on my own you
know I haven't even attempted to sell
them or or put them out or distribute
them in any way because I want to keep
them for myself so I can make them you
know so so it's a mixture of a lot of
different things they're things that I
keep to myself because I want to make
them myself and then there's other
things that are just out it's just not
no one's really into it right now
it's nature of the beast so there's an
ebb and flow it sounds like there's kind
of like - there's like a rest you know
I'm thinking of Simon and Garfunkel yeah
just um there's an F okay there's an ebb
like Evan flow sort of says like oh
isn't that and then there's a fun
there's an ebb a little bit of flow
mostly AB it's mostly it's mostly ebb
and and and it's your job to create the
flow that's what I think you know I
think that the best thing a writer can
do is to keep writing and then figuring
out where that writing fits in the
marketplace how you're gonna get it out
there who you're gonna take it to cuz
you have to be smart you have to know
what people were looking for you know
and that's a very difficult thing to do
you know you could write something great
there's not looking for it you know I
mean like television is a lot like that
you know television television is
programmed I was told this by a
television executive televisions program
not by what what's necessarily good but
what they need so if you've got a really
sort of poignant half-hour dramedy
that's really really good but what they
need is a silly comedy to come after
Modern Family
you know because that has to do with
business see that's the thing that's the
thing that's so difficult about this
business is people forget about the
business part you know there are
companies involved in fees paid to
networks for these shows and you know
you know those commercials that you see
in between the shows they factor in
because of the show like you know it's
not just this is brilliant it's like
okay well is tide cool with this to like
you know can we run out any commercials
here because it's it's all you know so
there's a lot of different factors that
have absolutely nothing to do with your
script that go into your script going
wherever it's going to go
you